hey guys in this video I want to share
with you just some information on what's
behind
plaquing in the arteries okay so this is
just a massive amount of confusion
that's out there in relationship to the
sequence of events that occur the exact
cause and effect relationship somehow
so-called science doesn't want to be too
positive and really say this causes this
everything is associated there's risk
factors and it puts the patient in a
massive confusion so let's just take a
look at some of the pieces of the puzzle
and then we can rearrange them in a
correct sequence of events amyloid
plaque anons in the brain Parkinson's
Alzheimer's so you have plaquing in the
brain and then you have also plaquing in
the arteries you can have em like
lacking in the liver and the kidney and
even in the pancreas that can actually
shut down the cells that make insulin
cause diabetes type 1 okay even make it
type 2 as well you can have this
plaquing in the joints as rheumatoid
arthritis so if you think about it you
have the brain you have the arteries you
have the gums as gingivitis and all that
blocking you have in the joints you have
all you have inflammation you have
plaquing you have all sorts of scar
tissue in there so there's an
interesting phenomena that's occurring
in different parts of the body okay so
when you go to the doctor you might they
might test for MLA plaquing there's a
medication for that they might find that
you have intracellular calcium or
calcium blacking so that's why we have
and you get high blood pressure that's
why you have calcium channel blockers
for that or you might have high
cholesterol so we give you put on a
statin or you might have high insulin
and we can put you in diabetic
medication or bacteria shows up and they
put you on some type of antibiotic or
high levels of white blood cell and they
put you on a cortisone shot right so you
have all these different things that
occur so my thought is let's take a look
at this and what would happen as a chain
reaction 1st 2nd 3rd and 4th ok here's
what I think that's happening
number one you start off with you don't
start off with high cholesterol you
start off with high insulin okay when
you have high insulin it makes the cells
in the vascular system the little cells
that compose what's called endothelium
it creates a leak in those cells okay
very similar to vici gut where you have
another set of inflammation and scar
tissue and the whole thing I didn't talk
about that so they're sort of leaking to
the artery wall and boom you're going to
actually stir up a hornet's nest with
the immune system okay so if you start
off with high insulin and it could be
other things too you could have very low
vitamin C which almost like a borderline
scurvy and create the same like ulcers
or a lesion in the artery wall as well
so we could have a vitamin C deficiency
let's say you're just a junk food junkie
that's going to create it to a lot of
stress in the vascular system or you're
an alcoholic all these things
nutritional deficiencies chemicals can
start this reaction but the the second
thing you get is artery damage
okay so we have artery damage it could
be damaging the joints and the liver in
the brain depending on your weakest link
in your body so after you get this
artery damage then guess what's going to
happen you're more susceptible to
bacteria at that point
okay now they've even found the same
microbes and gingivitis and your your
gums and your arteries okay so that's an
interesting coincidence so I'm wondering
what other part of the body it affects
too and then you'll get an immune
reaction that's number four so
inflammation is not really the cause of
these things it's the effect okay that's
what you need to straight now and then
what happens here comes the cholesterol
the cholesterol acts is a band-aid to
come in there so there's two types of
cholesterol and so there's two types of
LDL which is so-called bad cholesterol I
did a video on this I'll put all these
links down below you have type A and
type B type A is the big fluffy you know
type of cholesterol that doesn't
it's not involved in trying to do
anything with this artery wall type B is
very small and dense and those are the
guys that are always involved in trying
to heal this lesion in the wall okay so
how do you know if you have type A or
type B because they're usually combined
you can't tell you look at your
triglycerides if your triglycerides are
high and your HDL is low or possibly
normal then you have more B that means
that there's something going on there's
some type of healing going on there's
some type of something going on in your
body that you need to address okay so
this is not the villain this is the
thing that comes in is the chain
reaction is help try to put a band-aid
and try to heal this thing okay because
the cholesterol is there to actually
help heal certain things so we don't
want to completely lower this we want
understand what's happening so we have
this cholesterol then comes the amyloid
plaque n' okay or other types of fibrous
tissue this is all protein it's like an
it's a part of the band-aid you're going
to start getting stiffening of the
arteries if there's too much of this
then we get the calcium calcium starts
building up so we have this whole mesh
of this band-aid it's made from protein
calcium cholesterol that's all trying to
heal this area that's what your body's
trying to do so for someone to come in
there and start treating these without
understanding it is is completely
utterly insane so I just wanted to kind
of show you the sequence of events step
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 that's really the order of
things that occur and it's happening all
over your body so and I'll put a link
down below of what you need to do for
this culprit right here because this is
a big one and this actually will cause
high blood pressure and obesity but
obesity is the last thing to occur not
the first thanks for watching press it
forget it forget it I'm done press the
subscribe button and I will keep you
updated on the future events